es hora de repasar la actualidad
cultural en france24 para ello contamos
con nuestra compañera
periodista de cultura para hablar de los
premios césar que tuvieron lugar en
parís es la ciudad el lago y la gala de
los premios de la cultura y del cine de
francia na si rodrigo una celebración
cultural pero que no olvida la
actualidad como lo subrayó al director
rafael cardona en su discurso a recibir
el premio de mejor película revelación a
él recordó que si bien el cine puede
parecer inútil en estos tiempos
difíciles siempre hay nobles saint
producirá arte y hoy los equipos de
producción de dos películas en
particular pueden felicitarse por haber
cumplido los pronósticos la ópera rock
en inglés a nets con las estrellas mayo
y angustia el fabuloso adam driver ganó
cinco premios incluyendo un mejor
dirección para leos carax y el favorito
las ilusiones perdidas que tenía el
récord de 15 nominaciones ya salió con
siete estatuillas y la más importante
fue gala en la categoría más prestigiosa
de mejor película esta adaptación de una
novela francesa hace un retrato ha sido
del mundo de la prensa en el siglo 19
entre corrupción y lucha de clases
veamos el traidor
su nariz
[Aplausos]
[Música]
nos estáis subiendo
fuera abajo
disfruta que le gusta semana
pero
[Música]
pero lea durante esta gala hubo
bastantes más premios destacados verdad
efectivamente rodrigo pues hay que tener
paciencia para aguantar la pero vale la
pena por la alegría de ver algunos
artistas ganar premios bien merecidos
empezando por vale filonazi elegida como
mejor actriz por su papel como
protagonista de alina un falso verdadero
biopic sobre su ídolo la cantante
canadiense celine dion una película con
mucho ritmo que vale filme así también
escribió y dirigió y de otro lado la
mejor película extranjera ha sido
conseguida a 2 father el padre de
sorpresa un director francés florence de
legg quien explicó justamente en su
discurso de agradecimiento que había
adaptado su propia pieza de teatro en
inglés porque soñaba ofrecer el error
principal al gran actor estadounidense
anthony hopkins un sueño hecho realidad
y bueno the father ya había triunfado el
año pasado ganando 22 cargos pero
entonces la verdadera sorpresa llegó con
el premio de la mejor actriz segunda
atribuido a una actriz no profesional la
historia lo sana enfermera en la vida
real que interpretó su propio papel en
la facción la fractura de que tengo sino
la historia de una noche de tensión en
la sala de urgencias de un hospital de
parís en plena jornada de protestas de
los chalecos amarillos
de una persona con funciones de
paciencia como éste
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bueno lea cuéntanos cuál ha sido tus
momentos favoritos de esta gala de 2022
sin duda los pasitos de baile de
marginal a ganar su cesar de mejor del
mejor actor por su impresionante y como
siempre muy justa interpretación en de
subido durante su vida y de la alegría
divinamente mail a la emoción de los dos
homenajes de esta edición primero a la
leyenda jean-paul belmondo y más tarde
en la noche al muy joven a gaspar el
hielo su amigo y director viaje de lana
le rindió un tributo muy muy conmovedor
en la sala podríamos ver muchas lágrimas
por estos dos inmensos artistas del cine
francés que quedarán anclados en las
memorias por su presencia su talento y
su carisma y que mejor manera de
terminar esta crónica que animarles a
descubrir o redescubrir sus películas
muchas gracias lea sin duda un gran
momento para descubrir películas tenemos
un 2022 muy emocionante por delante
hasta aquí este repaso a la actividad
cultural sigan con nosotros en france 24
y